we can defer to the world health
organization which is
don't forget a public health
organization meaning
politics and health public means
politics
so it's got a political aspect too and
obviously they've been infiltrated
largely by china and they were carrying
water for china and helping china cover
up the illness early on
the world health organization though now
is coming out pretty strongly
against the primary method
of combating this virus namely the
lockdowns you you have people at the
world health organization
coming out and saying we need to not
only
focus on other treatments we actively
need to stop the lockdowns the lockdowns
are hurting everybody we in the world
health organization
do not advocate lockdowns as a primary
means of control of this virus
the only time we believe a lockdown is
justified
is to buy you time to reorganize regroup
rebalance your resources protect your
health workers who are exhausted
but by and large we'd rather not do it
just look at what's happened to the
tourism industry for example in the
caribbean
or in the pacific because people aren't
taking the holidays
looks what's happened to smallholder
farmers all over the world
because their markets have got dented
look what's happening to poverty levels
it seems that
we may well have a doubling of world
poverty by next year
we may well have at least a doubling of
child malnutrition because children are
not getting
meals at school and their parents in
poor families
are not able to afford it this is a
terrible ghastly global
uh catastrophe actually and so we really
do appeal to
all world leaders stop using lockdown as
your primary control method
develop better systems for doing it work
together
and learn from each other but remember
lockdowns just have
one consequence that you must never ever
uh belittle and that is
making poor people an awful lot poorer
that is dr david navarro from the world
health organization
you probably won't see that video or
hear that statement
very much around social media because
now
the social media are clamping down on
what they say is misinformation but it
has nothing to do
with the misinformation or the accurate
information about the virus
it has everything to do with politics
and this is only going to get worse
through the election the reason that we
still have lockdowns today
is because of politics you can look at
where the lockdowns are it always tracks
with people's politics
the places that the lockdowns exist
aren't doing particularly well on the
coronavirus you look at
the one of the toughest lockdowns in the
entire country was in new york new york
got hit worse
than anybody and the lockdowns didn't
seem to help actually in some cases
the lockdowns hurt there were studies
that show that this happened in italy
and in new york by the way
that by locking people inside
particularly with elderly family members
you actually were putting them in a more
dangerous position than you otherwise
would have seen we saw this with the
nursing homes in new york in new york
governor cuomo's policies
forced people who and sent people who
were sick with the virus
into nursing homes and guess what
happened there thousands and thousands
of senior citizens died
we won't be able by the way to have a
full picture of what happened
because cuomo is using his political
apparatus to shut down
any additional studies of what happened
that's what we're seeing i mean if you
if you log on to social media now it is
unbearable because
first of all every time you log on they
say did you vote did you register to
vote
i'm here if i'm on instagram i'm here to
see like funny pictures
if i'm on twitter i'm here to see mean
little sardonic comments i'm not there
because i need a civic education if
you're getting your civics education
from instagram
uh probably something has gone deeply
wrong in our society
but they want to do that because they
know that those users are more likely to
vote for democrats and so they're trying
to get you
to go out there and support their
candidates and they're trying to
suppress information
that counters the democratic narrative
whether it be on widespread unsolicited
mail and voting which is unprecedented
in our country
and obviously shows signs of being open
to fraud we've seen this recently in new
jersey
we've seen this in new york we've seen
this in texas
so you've got uh you've got those issues
and then you've obviously got
coronavirus any any comments that are
contrary to the democratic narrative
even if it comes from the world health
organization
even if it comes from the cdc's website
will be suppressed which is what's
happening right now
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]